jim and larry were brothers identical  twin brothers that were separated at  birth okay  jim had a dog named toy larry had a dog  named wow  jim they both married a woman named  betty yeah they both were chain smokers  and both set from migraines and bolts  over blue chevrolet and they both had a  son named james allen and they both  worked as a deputy sheriff and bolted  their son's name was james allen at the  age of 39 their past finally crossed for  the first time after jim lewis  discovered the contact details of  identical twin it didn't take long for  the similarities and their life stories  to unravel so that is irrevocable  evidence irrefutable evidence that it's  two souls one bod that is  yep dr bouchard said he was left  flabbergasted flabbergasted which which  is a word you don't hear nearly enough  anymore yeah you'd say now like oh i was  shocked really no i was flabbergasted  yeah okay i was flummoxed i was  flummoxed i was flabbergasted laying  down in my vestibule